c'est toujours agréable de recevoir une
vedette
ça l'est peut-être un peu moins pour
vous de subir le supplice de l'interview
car si la vedette subi le supplice les
téléspectateurs aussi
alors j'ai voulu s'il voulait innover et
avec enrico macias ça ne pose aucun
problème
nous allons pratiquer pour la première
fois et en direct
l'interview musicale
henri pons
dit rien des mois qu ajouté pas vu je me
disais qu'est-il devenu
tu vois enrico où étais-tu passé
je ne peux pas
marc ribot permets moi de te demander de
faire de ta famille
comment voter
et je
très bien excuse moi je me suis trompé
dans le texte le peuple un peuple
peu à peu
enrico vêtu qui demain
au tiers provisionnel
l écho je sais que tu vas passer bientôt
à de la guerre
dis moi quel sera le mois
à
à partir du mois de mars enrico voeu de
tous tout charme et dvd
veux tu gagnes la phase où tu vas
chanter
je chante au mieux et wii mote appelle
le médecin malgré lui va d'installer et
tout ça sans nous allons écouter
tu es prêt à les pacifier
elle
d'ailleurs
là